this seems to be the perfect scenario
for all those bulls in the market that
we got today with the jobs report right
yeah I mean this is a good report and
there's lots to like about it solid job
creation at 280,000 good net revisions
to prior months critically as you just
said wage growth two-point-three percent
the best monthly gain in two years
people are coming back into the labor
market all of this points to a healing
labor market so the market reaction was
textbook in terms of yields higher
dollar stronger the equity market is
torn it's torn between seeing good news
on the fundamentals and worrying that
this will make the Fed hike earlier than
they would like uh that's right because
it's interesting how much the credit
markets right mohammad the bond markets
moved in reaction to this in fact much
earlier and much more vigorously than
the equity markets mohammad why is that
so i think the bond market only look at
one thing which is prospects for
interest rates and therefore what's
happening on the economy and what's
happening on central banks and this this
report said you know what the economy is
strengthening we are bouncing back and
the Fed is likely to hike this year so
for that it was a clear message higher
yields the equity market is torn because
people realize that central banks have
been the marcos best friend mhm and they
would like the Fed to remain ultra-loose
so they worry about the hiking message
in today's number but at the same time
they look and say you know what we like
the fact that fundamentals are getting
better so the equity market is is in
this tug-of-war whereas the bond market
sees clearly that the two things are
aligned